[Music]
good morning Hank Hank those warm wishes
come from Uncle grandpa of whatevs org
he and I were out quite late last night
at Lindsey Robertson's birthday party in
an unrelated story I don't feel very
well thanks for doing such a great job
with the peeps punishment I look forward
to its completion tomorrow and I'm
pleased at the Brotherhood 2.0
foundation for decreasing suck levels
worldwide is off to a roaring start
thanks to your complete inability to eat
peeps quickly Hank you may be wondering
why today's video is a little late it's
because I'm feeling a lot of anxiety and
I've had a very busy day
first I spent three hours at the eye
doctor it was like this only it lasted
much much longer then they dilated my
eyes so I couldn't see anything then in
a dimly lit room the doctor told me I
probably have nothing to worry about I
probably have nothing to worry about
if I probably have nothing to worry
about then I definitely have something
to worry about don't tell me I probably
have nothing to worry about
that's not helpful tell me you're fine
congratulations
good work on those eyes kid then on the
way home I talked on the phone to you
during a terrible traffic jam well I
mean I noted certainly though you didn't
competitively eat the peeps then I left
my cell phone in his car but because
he's the world's nicest cab driver he
drove to my house and gave it to me so
everything worked out fine I probably
have nothing to worry about and I lost
my cell phone but then I got it back I
shouldn't be worried I should be happy
so why am I worried there's just this
big bundle of stress that I can never
get rid off I blame dad
I mean if dad hadn't had cancer when he
was my age I probably wouldn't worry
about having cancer by the way do you
know you can get eyeball cancer very
rare you probably won't get it but you
might then there's the big worry in my
life that isn't even my worry which is
that the Yeti is working on her master's
thesis and it's extremely hard and
extremely stressful and it just sort of
like occupies your whole life I've never
seen someone worked so hard on something
this morning I woke up and Sarah had
written herself a to-do list on a
post-it I want to read you that to do
see picture of dorian gray at butler
library pay bills call into question the
ideology of class call into question the
ideology of class that sounds hard I
wish I could say I was stressed out
because I was calling into question the
ideology of class I'm just stressed out
because I have to do laundry and I might
have eyeball cancer I'll see you
tomorrow